upsetting officer before i go any  further today i want to take this  opportunity to say how  sorry i am for my breach of rules that i  ask all of us to follow every single day  i took my face mask off while briefly  attending a funeral purvi last week  i'm sure everyone will have seen in the  media this morning a picture of me  without it i want to be clear today that  regardless of the circumstances i was in  the wrong there are no excuses these  rules  do apply to me just as they do to  everyone else and the rules  really matter i am kicking myself  very hard possibly harder than my worst  critic ever  could but more importantly i'll be  making sure i don't drop  my guard again